or he could just play a quieter opening
just keep the tension and uh see whether
dude's nerves hold up now that dude has
something to hold on to it's actually
hard as well for the polish player to
maybe look for objectively the best
moves when you
would be pretty happy with the draw
which i think duda would be here and i
was going to say maybe a petrov defense
dude has used that many times against
magnus in the past not this time
what will magnus choose the italian
opening
the spanish opening white slight square
bishop coming out magnus has chosen a
variety in this type of position but
he's pausing so magnus may be not
expecting
uh this early development dude actually
rarely does bring his knight to this
square rarely opens with the king's pawn
without playing the petrov defense and
the berlin
playing magnus's specialty against him
this is brave
and okay one of the main lines we did
see a bishop for nitrate black's pawn
structure is slightly compromised
but black does have the bishop pair
normally this goes to a kind of slower
maneuvering phase now where both sides
have to decide which uh which flank they
want to park their king on and uh okay
magnus maneuvering i haven't seen this
night move this early
uh at least
at least i don't think so in this exact
position is it a novelty it's not a
novelty
but it's only been played three times
before and uh
the last game was in march 29th between
federsafe and tomaszewski and that game
ended between those two strong russian
grandmasters in a draw
it makes sense white's knight wants to
maneuver around maybe to sit next to its
fellow knight
if the white king wants to castle on the
right side of the board then white's
knights will be very well placed
and no we do see aggression hello
hello
that is the kind of move that i like to
see why is this aggressive though
because normally um throwing pawns where
you might put your king is very risky
and obviously if white ever tries to
castle that way put his king on that
side like black has done then he's
pushed his pawn like his bodyguard you
know those pawns are used to protect you
they're your bodyguards but he's thrown
it forwards and uh instead this is
indicating that he's going to go for a
bit of a pawn storm we call it so he
might use that pawn and a couple other
pawns to just attack the black king
which is a really exciting dangerous and
very aggressive way to play the berlin
so i love it i love that move that's
that's uh very interesting right i mean
i did not expect that from from magnus
but he does need to win i guess so he's
got to take some risks uh incidentally i
think that this is a home-cooked idea by
magnus carlsen because whilst i was
looking at the previous moves i saw that
the computer was suggesting this porn
move
for for white and uh magnus by the speed
of his moves
just seems to know like he's in full
control he knows exactly what he's doing
and
look at that that rook slides one square
to the left which does mean this white
is uh priming to jump that knight to the
f5 square i mean it's really like a
reverse black line um
which is another chess of course i've
done but it's uh it's exactly the same
formation you can use as with the black
pieces uh this kind of idea um the only
slight problem you you often have is
playing with white well i say the only
one of the slight problems is you don't
really have a hook to latch onto so if
black had moved to porn around his king
side you'd have like something to latch
on to but you've got to force
force the opening here i guess by using
both of those pawns but this is very
very exciting stuff yeah this is just
brute force this is like caveman chess
just not caring about your own king not
caring about anything that's going on on
this side of the board just throwing
pawns towards the opponents
uh the opponent's monarch the opponent's
king so
yeah i love it as well
i don't really think it's magnus's style
necessarily but uh just for us it's
gonna be very entertaining it's not
gonna be a boring game this one queens
are not gonna come off anytime soon and
i do quite like what dude is doing kind
of in general it's a bit slow but dude
is just pushing pawns on the other side
of the board so now white's king has a
dilemma does it want to sit in the
center forever or if the white king the
only side it can castle on now is the
left side
it will castle into the firing line if
it ever dares
uh to castle so
magnus can get away with this we should
mention you can only get away with this
type of idea is if the center is blocked
and there are pawns in the middle that
can never really be removed things will
never get unblocked in the middle of the
board so that's why he can go for this
type of idea with a clear conscience uh
white's king pretty happy for now but uh
in the meantime all out attack and that
does begin with that typical maneuver
planting a night on the f5 square
the black king already feeling pretty
uncomfortable wow i don't think you
should take this knight because white's
pawn on the g5 would capture on white's
rook staring down at the black king on
that g line um yeah really scary stuff
exciting berlin a bit of an oxymoron but
um
and it's magnus who's made it exciting
and i kind of agree with david it's it's
not what you expect magnus to do
i mean he's a brilliant attacker but
it's he normally prefers to grind grind
like a grandmaster and uh here he's just
going for the all-out attack so
it's great seeing that other side to his
play as well what should we expect with
his king with him now making the king's
eye quite open with those pawns moving
forwards i think he's just going to
delay committing his king as long as
possible
magnus actually said this to me recently
at the olympia just an offhand comment
he was like oh and tried to do a david
and i was like
what he's like just not castle and i was
like do i not castle ah and he's like
yeah i noticed you sometimes forget or
kind of do it on purpose and just not
castle
and i i've done that and i guess in my
career but i never consciously did it it
was just uh just happened and i guess
he's trying to do the same here he's
just not going to castle his king he's
going to leave it
in the center of the board that white
king as long as he can maybe one thing
he could do later is just hint that
he'll castle uh on the left flank he'll
force judah to kind of commit his attack
on that left side of the board and then
he'll say no i'm actually just gonna sit
um the white king could always slide one
square to the right and it's relatively
safe there for now all right well people
should bring out the popcorn for this
game i suspect yeah it's going to be
exciting and as simon as simon said
magnus can do anything he he's the most
universal player out there maybe the
most universal player in history dude is
really committing to that left side just
in case the white king castle's there
but yeah the thing is magnus likes to
attack with his whole army and here he's
just attacking with a knight and a bunch
of pawns so far so
still a lot to be done uh white's bishop
needs to come out into the game white's
queen needs to improve herself white's
rook in the corner eventually we'll need
to join the fun but
uh shaping up heating up nicely this is
this is such a confusing position
because for me it's not really clear
like what black is attacking apart from
expanding on the left side of the board
and it's not really clear how white is
actually gonna start uh attacking the
black king maybe it's just both sides
are grabbing as much space as possible
and then
we'll see what happens next anything
goes
attacking thinner that's the new the new
fashion oh yeah i mean yeah i guess you
could try to we we call it a hook and i
was going to suggest this move here
actually uh trying to force uh a hook
and david can can show us what that is i
guess here yeah so this is an attack on
the queen actually the queen only has
one safe square so you only have two
options here either you move the queen
it's a bit of an awkward square kind of
blocking in your own bishop or as simon
says uh pushing the pawn forward is
maybe the most natural move kicking away
the bishop gaining time but when the
bishop retreats um this is the hook
right simon yeah and we call it a hook
because white now has something to latch
on to um and now you can break open the
position by force you need a pawn break
you need a pawn exchange in order to
open up lines and
for example if black i'm just going to
make a silly move here just moves the
bishop away then sudden okay he does
allow this brave stuff from duda but now
suddenly this line is going to become
open for sure that's guaranteed and the
black king feels
super uncomfortable so uh this is the
current position i don't think duda is
going to move his bishop out the way
because he needs to be ready to capture
this knight this really dangerous night
if he needs to
but again you don't want to capture it
right now because suddenly open lines
that's the currency
in the position and black's king
yeah it just feels like white is
attacking uh something at least
something tangible white is clearly
going for the black king but these pawn
pushers as ivanka said earlier i mean
that's not where the white king's
sitting yet
white's king hasn't committed i mean i
think magnus would be pretty happy just
sliding his king across one square later
talking of sliding across the black king
getting out of the line of the rook so
how is this frustrating for duda to play
he doesn't really know magnus's
intention especially with the king then
i would have thought he'd be quite
happy as well because he loves sharp
crazy positions and let's remember if he
wins this one which he's probably not
going to do normally let's face it if
magnus doesn't do something special then
you know he's you know but he can now
win this game um if magnus over presses
because it's one of those positions
where it's so sharp um uh you know so i
i i feel duder might be
feeling okay as well i'm not i mean i
just looked at the evaluation bar and
i'm quite surprised to see how high up
it is for four magnets
um but yeah i mean i don't know do you
think duda will be feeling okay here or
uh i think duda will be shaking
in his boots
that's what that's the expression right
that is certainly an expression
quaking in his boots yeah i thought it
sounded a bit strange i'm sure norwegian
is shaking in the pants in the past yeah
you're like you know your legs go like
oh
[Laughter]
um yeah i mean you're right simon it's
traditionally a dude a type of position
i think he'd rather be white definitely
he'd love to be white wouldn't he i mean
it's different defending these and
attacking he's he's known to attack so
yeah that's maybe the big difference
right
also i mean experience wise when i
choose an opening i always want to
choose something where i'm more
experienced or at least my understanding
is will match my opponents or surpass my
opponent's understanding
but here duda he's chosen an opening as
black that he doesn't play on a regular
basis
it's not his main weapon as black
whereas magnus he's been playing the
berlin with white and black since he was
in diapers since he was a kid
he's played countless world championship
matches where the berlin was the main
kind of battleground
so as ciavanko mentioned it might be a
home-cooked idea this one from magnus
but
even if he isn't in his theory even if
he's not 100 sure where the pieces go he
can feel it due to that uh kind of due
to years and hundreds of games hundreds
of training games uh in this type of
opening
oh yeah it's uh it's kind of stacking up
against duda but i do like the fact that
the polish player he's played quite
quickly not showing fear the last thing
you want to do when you're being
attacked is show your opponent that
you're afraid
so duda swinging his chair as well
looking pretty calm
yeah i think he's looking calm but i
don't know i think he's uh privately a
little bit stressed and uh whilst uh
magnus is considering how he's gonna
continue his attack well we have a
selfie competition
where we're asking tweet a selfie that
will impress our very own ginger gm
simon williams and the winner will get
simon's chest ball course on the hippo
defense and king of blunder says is
enjoying the live stream for round five
but really looking forward
for a new opening as well
there you see it's a hippo
right okay yeah i'm going to wait until
it pops off my screen but
yeah anything with a hippo in is good
you're in with a shout if you get a
hippo on there oh it is a proper hippo
did he just have a hippo mask just
casually lying around his house he's
like all right hang in a minute i'll get
my normal mask out the hippo mask how
many people have a hippo mask in their
house that is impressive filter yeah
whoa what's happening on the bar uh
magnus has just gone for it but
i don't know if this is the right moment
i mean it seemed like his king was going
to be you know it seemed like there's a
very simple solution to this i thought
um take the night push to pawn right i
mean that's what
i was thinking of i don't think this is
playable this move he's trying to break
open this line which is understandable
but um we did mention the bishop is
sitting on the square and it can easily
there we go get rid of the white knight
duda has captured and as you mentioned
simon suddenly the placement of white's
king it was safe as anything just one
move ago but suddenly black can crack
open the center we talk about opening
lines suddenly black's king's pretty
safe in the corner it's the white king
that's coming under fire i mean this
this just did not look playable david to
me he's suicidal i mean why king why
play this i mean what's he doing today i
mean [ __ ] moves the black queen can
come in i mean start attacking from this
angle just at the very least you pick
off this pawn
i i'm speechless i mean he he
i'm pretty it's a pretty simple sequence
this i mean if i can see it it's simple
um and
i don't understand you could have
prepared this in many different ways you
could have put the queen in front of the
king to stop this from happening before
you did this you could be just be a
little bit patient uh but instead he's
sticking first yeah i mean there's
many you didn't have to allow this and
this is the problem if you leave your
king in the middle you've got to make
sure as you said earlier david that you
control the center that you stop your
opponent opening lines in the center and
this goes against all and there we go we
have it on the board it goes against all
judgments that now black is opening the
center whose king is weakest here
certainly magnus is king i i i'm just
amazed by this actually uh really
what about you vancouver
i'm totally just astounded actually it
just seems like magnus is
self-destructing here i mean because he
had a great position he had full control
and now this is a position where
frankly black's pieces are all ready to
attack and what is white attacking with
i mean it's just a rook
i mean after pawn takes pawn that's it
the queen is not gonna get across to the
right side
and uh all the action is happening in
the center
yeah i mean what's queen is misplaced
white's bishop kind of gets in the way i
guess magnus's only hope is to somehow
land his bishop on this diagonal and
start going for the black king here but
uh yeah that feels like a pipe dream at
the very least at some point black can
just push upon and kind of take that
square away from the bishop i don't
think he needs to but uh yeah i mean
again the most natural move in the
position dude his moves just flow now
just bring the queen in
take this pawn
what is magnus doing his king is just so
weak you're not ready for this with a
rook in the corner with these pieces
clumsy this one this one is even more
surprising than the blunder in round one
because in round one there's a reason
behind it that he was going for the draw
he did a little miscalculation but this
one
very simple two move sequence which is
pretty obvious
and extremely obvious what did he miss
what what on earth could he have missed
to play this he had lots of time
and uh i i it's a bit bewildering
actually um and he doesn't seem like
surprised or or you know he hasn't
reacted like he did in the first game at
all yeah so it is a part of his plan
then
i mean it's so ugly for white uh unless
he's got this kind of a very specific
idea in mind maybe he wants to for
example take this pawn and after a
recapture put his bishop on this square
he is threatening checkmate now
by capturing this pawn with his bishop
but the problem is black can just take
this guy
and as simon mentioned there's only one
king that's weak right now and it's
white i mean you can sneak in from this
angle
the white knight is pinned because
otherwise there would be a checkmate on
this uh f2 square
i don't see it
what has magnus planned does he want to
bring his rook up in this position maybe
some ideas uh some kind of uh skewer on
this line because the white bishop is
really well placed the pawn can't
capture because it's pinned on this
diagonal towards the black king
but that feels like you're asking for
trouble after the queen just disappears
and gives a check after this track yeah
i mean um
i just don't see this working for black
you're asking for a lot from your
position from all your pieces uh if we
backtrack to the current position you're
asking for the position to open up for
this bishop to improve you're asking for
black to kind of not do anything for
three or four moves
yeah magnus in huge trouble
and yeah just look at the piece okay he
does trade these pawns
and uh but yeah just look at these
pieces black has three active pieces
centralized pieces
what are white pieces doing they're
mostly stuck on the back rank wow i mean
i mean another idea that i'm thinking
maybe magnus has in mind maybe not
putting the bishop on c3 but maybe
putting the bishop on h6
i mean can you do that and say hey let's
get in a check
yeah maybe this is his idea
uh
this is possible
trying to work out what black would do
here i mean firstly i'm not sure it's a
massive threat if black's queen just
takes a pawn white gives one check but
it's just a check
and when for example you move out the
way with a discover check for example
bishop takes pawn
the white rook hits the king now black
can just
block
yeah suddenly i mean black is playing
with all his pieces this rook is going
to swing across
i mean white's king is just uh
just doomed
yeah
it looks like a disaster zone for white
wow oh incredible stuff actually i think
he must have missed some had some
tactical idea in his position
uh but
i am missed that it didn't work or
something i mean i well i mean i'm
trying to make night
night into the towards black's king work
here um right sacrifices yeah i'm trying
to make something drastic work here
because the issue is if you if you don't
do something drastic here as white i
mean if you look at the placement of the
pieces black black's pieces are
controlling the center of the board
um black's king is in the corner which
will be actually very safe
um and white's pieces are are really
quite passive no none of those pieces
have really left the the starting ranks
they're all they're all back
hiding in bed um and black can get his
last rook into the game it's one of
those positions where if you don't have
something immediate
you're just collapsing here the position
will collapse because black's moves are
very very simple
so
um i don't see it i i can't see what the
any idea here like literally any idea
for for white
uh maybe
you know that keeps the game going even
you know it's uh it's tough right
massive trouble for magnus carlsen but
young christoph duda he could go up to a
two-point lead in the match what could
be a winning plan here for duda then i
think the beauty for duda is that he
doesn't need a plan his pieces are so
good he can just react so if magnus
tries to check mate him with those kind
of bishop moves uh that we were
suggesting the black queen he's just
going to slide across
to take a white pawn the black queen is
just going to slide across across two
squares i think you you can play that
against nearly anything um you're just
going to win a pawn first of all and
then just defend that pawn defend the
king you don't even need to go for the
white king anytime soon just black's
pieces are ready so as long as you kind
of react and defend against magnus's
threats you know that you will be
having a huge advantage as black maybe
even extra pawns extra material
um
yeah duda doesn't even need to kind of
think okay which piece am i going to
improve which piece am i going to put
where it's just about
calculation and as long as he's not
getting checkmated black then he's just
winning i think
yeah it's just
i'm struggling to explain it as well
simon because like you said the last
game was hallucination it was kind of a
mind fart as we call it just something
just went wrong for magnus but this one
it's just um
that's the type of mistake that he would
have made maybe when he
i mean when he was very young and then
he learned okay kings in the center you
have to be really careful to handle them
yeah this is why we castle it just
almost feels like he forgot that
jan christoph duda actually had some
chances had some attacking possibilities
and he thought it was all one-way
traffic and maybe i would just say he
forgot about this porn move even though
it is pretty obvious and what are we
well katuda there very comfortable
looking like he's uh he knows that he
has a great position i mean magnus has
spent like four minutes now as well so
he is clear he just missed something i
mean he this is only a couple moves
after he instigated this sequence of
moves and
you know
magnus can see fervent three moves ahead
um
so
he missed something and he's probably
realizing now just how bad his position
is well you probably realize very
quickly yeah and uh
he i guess he's just trying to find some
way to to keep the game going yeah it
takes under five minutes now magnus
carlsen on the clock yeah it's bad okay
he does threaten checkmate in one move
white's bishop if it has time to go and
capture the f6 pawn it's checkmate uh if
you can capture a pawn near the black
king okay he tries this variation we
actually showed a couple of minutes ago
so that white rook
um it wasn't possible to capture it due
to a pin on the long diagonal black's
queen gave a check
here they looked like i mean it looks
like there are multiple solutions the
black rook in the middle of the board
could slide across
i like how the bar number suddenly just
revolves
i mean
i think just the rook coming over is
looks very simple simple doesn't it i
mean i
there i say simple but he's
yeah i mean i mean there's
this move just seems very good right i
mean you might the best form of defense
is attack
and with that last move um
duder has now got the attack he's got
this queen that can check the black the
white king he's got the bishop pointing
down he's a porn up
it's it's all going his way at the
moment yeah if anyone's gonna get mated
it might be white and uh
yeah i mean here there is still a threat
magnus has to deal with it i mean
maybe you just bring the knight out so
the rook can come in guard that fret
yeah at some point i don't know if you
check first and
i don't see how how white can stop
checkmate in actual fact just defend
this pawn and like you said the rook is
swinging across
i mean i think i'm not 100 sure i think
i would play it now i mean if you give a
check at least you give white the option
of blocking
and maybe the white queen is now a bit
more free to come out but you're right
simon just this idea just defend your
pawn
uh swing your rook across
how is magnus getting out of this one
i mean can he try the same idea of just
uh offering a queen trade we've often
said uh
that you know when your king is feeling
a little bit of pressure trade of trade
of queens yeah maybe there's something
stronger than that nightmare because
this maybe it seems like magnus is
defending that badly survivor barely
surviving is a better yeah better better
analogy definitely but yeah i mean maybe
this is his best chance his only chance
uh to try and save the game magnus i
mean there's not a rook rook attacking
the queen here is there i mean that that
doesn't work for many reasons actually
oh in the current no bishop takes paul
now i mean that's just uh in the current
position just looking for something it
looks one of those positions where it
could be a killer blow um but
yeah maybe just
it doesn't have to be um
i mean i'm just wondering i saw the
evaluation bar go down duda had
something better so i'm just wondering
if we backtrack a couple of moves this
was clearly the threat uh threat of
checkmate actually taking the pawn
trapping the king
maybe he could have just
defended against it hitting the white
knight
because the white rook is never
threatening to take this bishop for
example because then the white king is
the one checkmated
maybe this was just a cleaner kill
for duda uh if we backtrack a couple of
moves i yeah maybe keeping this rook on
the board was the easiest way but now
after this
uh exchange at least magnus okay he's
still losing
but i still up all down but uh at least
he has some hope i think for magnus he
just needs to escape this one with a
draw just get out of this game it's not
been uh not been pretty
and uh yeah i think this is the idea as
you guys mentioned just wiped just
begging for a queen trade hoping to uh
swap the queens off and
still an unpleasant end game if uh if
that even happens maybe black just keeps
the queens on by retreating his queen
and uh
uphill struggle but he's alive
the world champion is alive in this game
this is so intense magnus carlsen could
be about to go two points down in this
match and if that happens he will have
to win the two last games to take it to
tie breaks
or can he save this game is there a
chance of also winning the game then all
possible
results or not right now
uh he is fighting to survive in the game
it's just survival i think that's the
only thing that can be on his mind
magnus he's got to forget that he played
some okay he does retreat the knight
asking for that queen trade he needs to
forget that he did play some odd moves
and
wow flashy stuff from duda
his idea is that the white queen can go
up and take the black knight but black's
bishop is going to actually start
attacking the white knight
this is a nasty pin that the white
knight finds itself in
that's very strong yeah very very strong
and i guess white has to continue with
begging for queen trade again because
you know white's king is so vulnerable
and so shaky
better to just say i'm going to be down
in material
back in game
and
whilst uh magnus is uh waiting i know
this is so tense but can i provide some
light relief yes
okay
by the way i did see a great tweet from
is it just fox i don't know if you got
that one but it was a really good one
but yeah i think it was up earlier but
sorry
okay okay okay well anyway we might see
the game finished very quickly oh
yeah threaten uh threatening checkmate
this last move from duda black's queen
just wants to come down and take the
white knight look at black bishop look
at black's queen they're both teamed up
against that piece
you can't defend it maybe the only way
is to give up white's bishop to deflect
away the black queen temporarily
you could throw a pawn in the way of the
diagonal between black's bishop and the
white knight
it's just i mean it's just a temporary
thing it looks like you will be at least
two pawns down
maybe still some life uh maybe you can
give back a piece at the right time
magnus needs miracles though
he's still not looking happy but this is
good he's settling in he knows he needs
to be resourceful he knows he needs to
be tenacious
and he goes for a king walk
whoa magnus carlsen look with the queen
on the board yeah with queens on the
board the black's rook is coming in did
you see dude's look of disgust he was
like you can't get away with that mate
plus 11 the evaluation bar says
do you like how it was just like all the
numbers suddenly changed
11.
yeah no you can't do that i mean okay
let's see where is it gonna hide
first the night drops okay well one
thing we should mention is that white
does have a very deadly check or on the
board you know he's threatening to go
bishop takes pawn that would be a killer
blow unfortunately it is black to play
and unfortunately your two pawns down
and unfortunately black can just defend
that threat and win
but maybe he can checkmate you
immediately uh
so yeah it's uh definitely a lost
position for magnus
he doesn't look too interested in this
game anymore just looking away there
i think uh very minimum black's rook
comes
across and defends a pawn
first due to give some threats uh some
checks sorry he does centralize the
black queen very sensible
there must be a killer blue i'm not
seeing it yet but you don't need it i
guess
you still have the luxury of two extra
pawns a safer king seven minutes on the
clock seven minutes on the clock you
gotta be professional these days and you
gotta repeat the position twice and then
you say you wanna draw no thank you
i was just playing with you yeah so dude
i can give a couple of checks gain a bit
of time on the clock if he wants to rub
it in
show magnus who's the boss
what is up with magnus today a very rare
blunder in the first game he usually
comes back very strong after a loss
he comes back in terrible fashioning
game too what is up it was just a great
opening and then one really bad move um
that bad move was inexplicable
inexplicable simon uh you mentioned it
but
yeah this is the consequence he's only
played one bad move this whole game
magnus but he's got a lost position
because that's what happens at the top
level if you take your eye off the ball
um if you're careful careless just for
one moment and maybe don't stay true to
your style because you did say this is
not magnus's style this game yeah i mean
when he's beaten dude in the past on the
tour many times
there have been one or two attacks here
and there but mostly it's just been kind
of smooth smoothly out playing getting a
small advantage in the opening kind of
and that just grows step by step he very
rarely kind of keeps all the tension
imbalances things
um okay black did give a check and now
the black rook defends
that very important f pawn
so just a small time out there from duda
but look at the white king it's back on
its starting square
he would love to castle right now magnus
carlsen he would love to pick up his
king castle but you can't once you've
moved uh your king or your rook i was
going to say maybe you should try it but
you can't even do it because you're
playing you're playing online you know
you can pretend just very casually
castle and just see what happens and
but when you're playing online the
computer won't actually allow you to do
it so it's like you can't yeah that's
true
and also but i have to say that if you
did do that in an over-the-board event
your opponent could suddenly jump and go
touch move well you don't know this is
the next best thing to cut castling
you're trying to castle well you can't
even do that
by hand look dude is pre-moving now he's
checked and he's checked again and he's
pre-moving he's assuming that magnus is
going to play king moves which are
actually forced
and uh
he makes it deadly maybe his rook's
coming in with he can guard that square
or something yeah
did you guys see that at the olympiad uh
sam shackleton pre-moved over the board
he assumed his opponent would check him
and he touched his king moved it and
then he realized his opponent didn't go
the whole way and he had to move his
king and he had to resign because any
king move was losing on the spot key
match that as well i mean that was
america versus armenia i think and uh it
was yeah i mean don't pre-move and here
we go resigns
wow
huge drama not only in this match you
guys it's huge drama in the fdx crypto
cup magnus crawls and loses the second